what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so who you guys are a tough crowd I
did a Twitter poll which by the way if
you guys don't know follow me on Twitter
comments explained I did a Twitter poll
and I asked you guys who our next video
should be on how to kill Supergirl what
superhero or super villain whatever
should we kill in the next video and you
guys said Lobo which is DC's Wolverine
base for DC's will Wayne a Punisher and
this is a difficult one because he's
effectively immortal and we'll find out
why so as we always do with these videos
on how to kill superheroes we're going
to start out with who he is and then
were going to go into his powers and
then we're going to see if we can't
figure out a way to kill him so Lobo
first appeared in omegamin number 3 in
1983 but didn't really catch on with
readers at the time and so while he made
a few appearances in various titles
throughout the next few years
DC attempted to revamp his character by
giving him his own miniseries in 1990
where his origin story was changed now
in this miniseries it was revealed that
Lobo was the last surviving member of
the zarnian race I think it is and the
reason why he was the last surviving
member is because he killed everybody
else on his planet and so we actually
find out in a 2006 Newsarama interview
with co-creator Keith Giffen that Lobo
was reimagined as a leather-clad ultra
mountain biker in order to be a parody
of sorts for some of the ultraviolent
anti-heroes that were becoming extremely
popular in Marvel Comics
at the time most notably Wolverine and
The Punisher now Geffen who is noted for
a more lighthearted style of
storytelling in a superhero stories was
not a fan of the gritty trend that was
becoming the new norm and many of the
comics review was going through and so
where he attempted to poke fun at it
readers embraced the newer Edgar version
of Lolo with open arms then he actually
became one of DC's most popular
characters in the 1990s even going up
until now and so with that out of the
way let's move on to the discussion of
Lobos powers which i think is what most
of you guys care about so one thing we
have to keep in mind was Lobo is that
again he was written by several
different writers throughout his time in
comics so the extent of its powers has
varied widely depending on who was
writing in for the purposes of this
video we're going to focus on the
character of Lobo as he was most
frequently written and
as you is most frequently perceived so
this means that we're going to be
talking about the pre new 52 version of
Lobo which is the version that most
people think of in the DC Comics
universe and the one that we are going
to be seeing in the DC we were Justice
League of America series and we're going
to completely ignore the new 52 version
because that version sucks so ah if Lobo
has super strength and superhuman
durability and is with regards to these
two powers that a previous statement
about different writers writing Lobo
differently comes into play there have
been times for instance when level of
strength is really nothing to write home
about he's had a little bit more
strength than a normal human but that's
about it but in other times Lobo has
been strong enough to trade punches with
Superman and in fact Superman's even
said that Lobos traits combined with his
quickness make it impossible even for
someone as fast as Superman to react to
Lobos punches Lobo has broken constructs
created by Hal Jordan with the greatest
of ease and Hal Jordan stated that
containing Lobo with one of his
constructs would take his complete and
total concentration and willpower with
no distractions in any form or fashion
and in fact just to get an idea of how
ridiculously overpowered Lobo has been
there was an instance where he literally
spit in a dude's face and it killed him
this fit goes through the guys skull
like a bullet and the dude dies now to
complement his insane strength Lobo has
a ridiculous level of durability he's
been punched into outer space and gurus
spaceship by Superman without sustaining
any damage whatsoever he shrugged off
Superman's heat vision and he survives
an explosion that reduced an entire
planet to rubble but what makes Lobo
simply ridiculous and absolutely
elevates him to a comical level is his
regenerative healing factor and just
theme music from Superman the animated
series now remember that when we started
this conversation we said that Lobo
started out basically as a parody of
several characters including Wolverine
and so because of that Wolverines
healing factor is basically amped up to
11 with Lobo there was one occasion
where Lobo regenerated himself from a
pile of charred bones and it's been
confirmed that Lobo can grow an entire
body from a single drop of blood his
head has been disintegrated and Lobo
kept fighting while a new one grew back
and Lobo was once reduced to merely his
soul and never seen as a possessive
snail and used the tissue of that snail
to
recreate his own body so yeah I guess as
long as there's a drop of blood or maybe
like a soul Lobo just cannot die so he
just cannot be killed not only that
lives where this work gets really crazy
not only that Lobo can generate new
Lobos from a single drop of blood
meaning that he could basically cut
himself and create an army of Lobos it's
it's ridiculous but not only is he does
he have a regenerative healing factor in
Marvel Comics Wolverines immortal or at
least believed to be immortal because of
the sealing factors Lobo is genuinely
immortal because he's been banished from
both heaven and hell he can't go to
either place just because of all the
things that he's done so this is the
question it how do we kill someone who's
legitimately immortal well the first
thing we have to do is try to use magic
it always comes down to mattress first
since Lobo has been granted immortality
which literally means that he can't be
killed the only way around this is to
rid him of his immortality now since we
said that Lobo got his immortality from
the fact that neither heaven nor hell
could handle him in order to make him
mortal once again it's likely going to
take an act of either divine or demonic
nature and so that gives us a few
options there are a few characters in DC
Comics that are tied into divine power
by the Specter the presence and Michael
the Archangel furthermore there are
several other entities that are tied
into demonic forces like Trigon Etrigan
and Lucifer Morningstar now it seemed
that any of these powerful entities
would be able to remove Lobo from his
immortality and that ability could even
extend to any of the magical characters
in DC Comics like dr. fate cetana
or John Constantine but that's just the
first step even if Lobo is no longer
technically immortal he can still heal
from pretty much any injury with a
single drop of blood or organic matter
that would allow him to reconstitute
himself as to what we would need is
someone who can either transmit matter
or destroy matter like firestorm or even
dr. Manhattan so basically the
combination of literally destroying the
molecules that make up Lobo or
transforming them into a non organic
material which could negate Lobos
ability to regenerate and then turning
around and using some kind of divine or
mystic force to keep his soul from
inhabiting another living being might
just be a trick for killing him failing
that it's likely what it takes any one
of the reality Warblers in DC's universe
like mr. Mitchell Felix disappear amou
Lobo from existence I mean technically
it's not the same as killing him let's
in slow-mo appears to be pretty much
impossible to kill I don't feel a little
bit bad about cheating but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you guys have an
idea on how to kill someone like Lobo
feel free to leave a comment down below
if you guys have an idea on what
character we should kill next feel free
to post back here okay down in the
comment section and I will catch you
guys later please
[Music]